so you have to do your own fine path
integral over the space of mathematical
ideas there is a bit of that yes
what's your greatest strength as a
mathematician or some of your strengths
who says i have
strengths what's your greatest weakness
i'm a lazy bum
are you being modest when you say that
because i imagine someone who has an
accelerated degree two-year degree that
should ordinarily take four years it's
not as if you spend the majority of your
time playing video games and
and being on industrious oh you'll be
surprised
uh
i mean of course i didn't play video
games and that was back in the 80s
you know video video games came later
but
i definitely killed a lot of time
so who are you comparing yourself to
when you say that you're slothful
gee i compare i compare myself to who i
want to be
anyway
what are my strengths is
uh
i think i'm decently good at explaining
things to others
um
often that involves thinking about them
i mean
explaining is not just uh
reproducing what you've heard somewhere
else i mean it's it's first of all
being creative about these things
um
but you know
uh
ask the students
ask the people who listen to me in
lectures
when i give research lectures
um
it's very hard to
uh
you know
there's a famous uh story about einstein
that um
uh somebody complained to einstein about
his problems with math
and the reference was to high school
math like i never got high school math
and einstein said let me assure you that
my math problems are way bigger
uh
so
uh
meaning what what did he mean by that
you know i
einstein spent
all his life struggling with mathematics
not just high school time
okay so in a similar way uh gee i'm uh
sorry i mean now it might sound like i
need some analogy which i do i'm not
making
i understand trust me uh but but still
um
you know i like to implement
i like to compute things
implement them on the computer
which means that i spend a lot of time
programming the concepts i work on
turning them into running programs
you could say it's my strength
but when i look at it
all i see is that i'm struggling and
struggling and struggling and failing
and here and then here and there there
is a minor success
which gets superseded a little bit later
by somebody else
so
um
yeah maybe one of my strengths is the
ability to implement things
to turn to to actually
you know turn mathematical concepts into
running programs
uh
but it's also one of the things that
that keeps me depressed
so much of my time
some people who are watching this they
may be discouraged because they were
they weren't particularly great at high
school mathematics or some people may
have struggled during their undergrad
what advice do you have for those people
if they want to continue to learn
mathematics or physics at a
graduate perhaps even larger than
graduate phd level
do they just continue
plugging away and not feel discouraged
because they feel like in imbecile on a
daily basis
what advice do you have for them
there is chagalong
and there is realize when it's not
working
and i hate to tell you that i don't know
i mean i can't give you a a
a clear recipe to decide which one it is
um
different people are different
some people struggle and struggle and
struggle until
they succeed sometimes some people don't
uh or they struggle and struggle and
struggle and don't succeed
um
you get
uh
feedback
i mean
some people depend on daily feedback
some people can leave with a feedback
with a bit of feedback once a year
i i'm not sure i have
a a clear answer
what did you learn from ed whitton with
respect to mathematical techniques or
meta mathematical so how you should
think about math
or physics
well i learned specific mathematics from
him
right so you know i learned like many
other people i learned this formula
from him
right and how to read it and how to use
use it interpret it work with it right
do things with it
but i learned many other specific things
with him
from him
um
i learned from him he's actually um i
mean like
people think of him as a great
um
researcher
but he's also a great expositor
so
uh
when you come to his lectures
he is
able to make
even very complicated things appear
simple
uh the problem is that
often you will not see that because he's
turning the hyper complicated into
merely complicated
uh so so so so so you don't
automatically realize uh what a great
exposition
uh work he had done
and i i
think i learned well i don't know if i
learned that from him
but i strive to learn that from him
and then in other ways i
there are senses in which i didn't learn
anything from him
namely
he is
so much more talented
there's just no way of no other way of
saying it the guy is smart
the guy is extremely productive
if you try to imitate his
brilliance
you'll fail
at least i failed
if you try to imitate his productivity
or just be disappointed
so
um
in some ways i haven't learned there are
certain things i haven't learned from
him and i just simply couldn't
you